demain alors ça s'appelle un bouchon un
sourire donc tous les bouchons de
boisson il faut ramasser et alors ce qui
est génial dans cette association s'est
déjà frais de fonctionnement 030
centimes ouais on demande absolument pas
de pognon aux gens alors demande juste
de faire une action d'amour quoi c'est à
dire qu'il peut être fait par les petits
et les grands au lieu de jeter le
bouchon à la poubelle on met dans un
carton et après on le donne on a trouvé
un mec qui rachète les bouchons qui les
recycle donc en plus c'est écologique
parce que le plastique ça dure trois
mille ans et on va gagner du pognon avec
ça et on va pouvoir faire la
démonstration que ce qui manque c'est
pas le pognon c'est l'amour ouais et que
voilà sans rien demander au lieu de
jeter leurs poubelles on met dans le
truc on ramasse les bouchons il me faut
encore des bigarchons dans chaque
département il faut au moins qu'il ya un
mec a piqué un local et puis dès qu'il a
dix tonnes de bouchons web a bien un
camion qui arrivait elle embarque les
bouchons terminait et effectivement il
faut absolument rien donner à qui que ce
soit les gens aussi envie de le faire
ils le font si l'on prend vie ouais eh
ben ils le feront leur effet reconnu
pognon et le pognon alors là on va le
redistribuer d'une manière forcément un
petit peu arbitraire il ya des tas de
gens qui vont dire bah moi j'ai besoin
pour sa très bon va acheter des
fauteuils parce qu'il ya une association
qui nous a aidés là dessus les gosses
les enfants dans les lycées nous ont
vachement aider à 150 lycée qui se met à
ramener les bouchons sur les stades on
est obligé de débouchés les bouchons
parce que ça fait un projectile fermé
donc on récupère les bouchons partout et
tout le monde s'y met et ses magnifiques
parce que parce que je peux dire aux
gens maintien lors cette semaine vous
avez mis que deux bouchons on sait pas
énorme sur le papier au niveau de la
générosité ça ferait pas grand chose
mais peut-être reste une prochaine tu
vas me donner un petit peu plus
la nouvelle
date il alors vous n'êtes pas que les
[ __ ] la d'habitude c'est exemple
voilà cette époque de l'année la faute
sinon là parce que je me suis un peu
reposé mais j'y suis je fais le jeu fait
l'émission de télé bien sûr et donc qui
va selon va l'enregistrer à lyon dans
quelques jours et elle sera diffusée je
suis pas comme dans un mois un mois et
demi et voilà vous réagissez comme ans
aux propos de bernard vivier la semaine
dernière dans cette émission qui disent
actuellement les à foirer bon cela coûte
pas grand chose parce qu'ils se font
plaisir il chante sur une selle les gens
les applaudissent et en plus ils donnent
un air humain vous réagissez comme bien
sûr c'est plus que tout le monde dise et
ça c'est que de dire dès que tu te mets
dans le camp des gentils et essaye de
faire quelque chose pour une bonne cause
il y aura toujours des gens que je vais
je ne donnerai pas de hadj actif mais il
ya toujours des gens qui vont dire ouais
alors on profite de se mettre en avant
pour dire moi je suis un bon garçon puis
je vais chanter non je crois que que
tous les gens qui vont là bas ils qui
chante et c'est jean jacques goldman
quant à elle contre aucun des acteurs du
truc et il fédère surtout tout le monde
parce que tout le monde ne pourrait pas
faire venir
70 80 90 chanteurs parmi les plus grands
chanter je crois qu'en plus c'est une
belle fête et que tout le monde est très
très contents de voir des gens qui ne
viennent pas pour chanter leurs chansons
mais pourrait qu'ils viennent pas pour
vendre quoi que ce soit que que de
l'amour et donc c'est une entreprise de
toute façon formidable lavilliers ce
qu'il dit la charité c'est quand on
n'arrive pas à imposer la justice
bien sûr mais c'est le mans si jamais on
veut l'imposer autrement on ne peut rien
imposer sur la lettre sur l'écrit sur la
loi c'est impossible c'est cessé depuis
je crois que jésus l'a formidablement
bien dit aux gens du sanhédrin qui lui
disais mais pourquoi tu respecte pas la
loi pourquoi est-ce que tu tu sauves tu
fais un miracle jour de shabbat et jésus
a dit kikis à raison celui qui sauve le
jour du shabbat celui qui laisse mourir
lequel d'entre vous ne va pas aller
rechercher une brebis égarée le jour de
shabbat on va rester dans le sujet on va
faire une interview prise de tête